so I've been doing this ten things you
missed series that's a great way to
explore dark souls2 with you guys much
better than a let's play wouldn't you
say
and so far I've covered majulah things
betwixt the pit and the forest and you
know what on every damn episode so far
I've written it produced it released it
and then promptly discovered another
awesome fact about the place and usually
it's a really good fact because you know
it's something I missed as well when I
was combing every inch of the area for
fascinating little details so that's
what this episode is it's a compilation
of all the missed facts in previous
episodes so like if you learned
something new dislike if you didn't and
see if you can get 10 out of 10 let's
start off by seeing what I missed in my
majula 10 things the first is something
I didn't include because I simply could
not manage to get footage of it
happening so we all know how depressed
and serious the Emerald Herald is but
did you know that it's possible to catch
her in a good mood once in a blue moon
you can catch her swinging her legs like
a child something that I only saw happen
once in my about hundred hours of play
time for those of you who have had the
good fortune of playing demon souls
you'll recognize that this is actually a
reference to the maiden in black from
that game this action is completely out
of her character but anything's better
than hearing Mara
see Seaquest over and over again number
two didn't even exist in majula when I
made that first 10 things video did you
know that as of the 6th of June 2014
from is running a promotional campaign
for their new DLC within the actual game
that's right each week until the first
piece of DLC is released on July 22nd
new items will be in the chest in the
medulla mansion I'll put these things on
screen for you guys apparently we'll be
getting a secret item on July 22nd and
let me tell you I am not opening their
chests without hitting at first it's
definitely got to be a mimic right
number 3 relates to the plaque on the
back of the Manjula obelisk so we've all
wondered at this text thinking maybe it
could be unlocked somehow through our
actions in-game the letters are worn
beyond recognition but not in Portuguese
upon patch 1.04 Portuguese players of
Dark Souls 2
noticed that the plaque had its
description changed to the Giants
crossed the Seas perhaps to return home
this is a really interesting error
perhaps made by the Portuguese
translation team at the very least it
reveals that the obelisk is a war
monument erected after the war it even
has a deathcounter you know almost like
a memorial to the people that fell at
most we learn the drangleic was the
original home of the Giants which could
have some fairly significant law
implications remember though this text
may have been removed from the game for
a reason so it's hard to say anything
inferential for if you use a bonfire
ascetics on the medulla bonfire twice
then you can finally become the true
monarch butterfly talk to morlun and
he'll sell this set that extends your
jump distance and poisons everything
around you including NPCs it's a really
good way to ruin your game next two
points were missed in my forest 10
things video we're up to number 5 now
there's this bit of text in the guide
that questions whether the fire in
Cardinal tower is naturally occurring
and spawned to the salamanders or
whether the salamanders are responsible
for the flame around them well just kill
them and you'll find your answer because
if you slay all the salamanders all the
pillars of fire will be extinguished all
right number 6 at about 50% health the
last giant will rip off his dead arm and
use it to extend his reach he's that
desperate to kill you you'll actually
notice that he's really reminiscent of
the giant Lord and him having this need
to hold a weapon kind of seals the
connection for me there but that's not
the point did you know that you can cut
off his arm preemptively just put
yourself in a more risky position to
focus your attacks on it and it'll fall
off once you've dealt about 50% of his
maximum health to his arm exclusively
which makes the whole process pretty
redundant really your time is better
spent hitting one leg and then dashing
to the other anyway discovering this one
fact made me pretty sad actually because
I know that if this was dark souls 1 I
would have got a weapon out of that 7
let's move on to the pit the first point
I want to talk about is something I read
in the comments of my pit
video cheers - Kotori gays Joker for
tipping me off on this one so he said
that there was a zip line hidden in the
gutter and I was like what I thought I'd
been completely thorough when I explored
the gutter but after a lot of searching
I eventually followed the zip line cable
above and found out where to access it
so after that first exploding undead on
the bridge you should continue along in
that direction until you find this
corner drop-off explore climb up and
eventually you'll find these items and a
zip line that allows you to skip what is
essentially half of Blighttown 2.0 I
could not believe this existed I thought
who knew it all I'm going to leave a
dislike on my video out of shame moving
on to something else I missed in the
gutter number eight
you know those sconces that you can
light in this area I didn't notice it
before but they're essentially
repurposed statues with their heads cut
off the body has lost its form but at
the base of each one is the severed head
of a statue with number nine and ten we
move on to areas that I'm not planning
on having full episodes on because they
only have about one or two hidden things
within them so first up at number nine
is dead man's Wharf you call the pirate
ship in by ringing a bell but did you
know that you can bypass a chunk of the
stage by shooting an arrow at this bell
instead you can essentially bring the
ship in from across the map with an iron
arrow I set off the bell which rings to
bring the ship in early that's a pretty
neat little detail and finally I debated
including the dark chasm in my pit video
but ultimately I decided against it
there's this one neat fact in this place
though and it's in the dark chasm of
drangleic castle when you go down there
you can peek through the stone here at
the end of the stage and you can see the
best boss in the game waiting for you on
the other side and honestly I kind of
just included this fact so that I could
talk about this boss so dark loka is an
optional boss you get from exploring all
three dark chasms and he's got to be the
best boss fight in the game hasn't he
this was my first time fighting him and
it's one of those fights where you can
just marvel at the design so it starts
off it's just you and one dark lager he
has a melee combo an AoE self explosion
for ranged methods of attack I think and
also a teleport
now the thing about his attacks is
they're all incredibly easy to predict
firstly each one is a different color
with a melee combo he takes a moment to
conjure the bright spell sword and it
also uses a combo that can be really
easily dodged by pretty much just
spamming the Dodge button in regards to
his ranged attacks he conjures three
colored spheres and all of these hover
above his head for a few seconds before
firing which allows you to take in
what's about to happen
one is fire shooting a series of
explosive fireballs in quick succession
another is a dark spell he'll conjure
two dark portals and should a dark orb
into one which will fly out of the other
towards you which will explode and knock
you off your feet upon nearby impact
with the ground he can also signal for a
type of light purple soul arrow to fly
at you from his hands his fourth attack
is a purple laser something that will
start off slow but track your movement
and force you to run and keep away so
since you can predict all this it's
gonna be pretty easy right wrong these
were only easy in order to train you for
what's about to come now that you've
been given ample time to memorize the
visual cues dark lager splits in two you
now have to deal with a flurry of
attacks that threaten to overwhelm you
but these are attacks that are really
predictable and in an arena that's quite
manageable it's a fight where you have
to manage your camera well but also one
where you're forced to anticipate two
opponents they've done a brilliant job
of balancing the speeds and the timing
of his attacks it feels like you're
performing this intricate dance every
time you fight for example you might
know that one of these fireballs is
about to fire so you need to run the
perfect amount of distance to put you
into striking distance of the other dark
loka is one firing a laser I should try
and run underneath him at an angle where
I can keep both in my camera so you know
these are the things that you're
thinking you're constantly in this
ongoing focused state of mind now
compare this to another duel fight that
I hate the throne defender and watcher
so in this fight you're constantly
backpedaling waiting for both enemies to
attack at once just so they'll both be
open and in my opinion this is just
shitty boss design it's not fun or
satisfying to fight that way and their
attacks aren't
which means you're actually forced to
backpedal if you could predict their
attacks it would still be hard because
there's two of them but at least you
could get in the thick of it and cut
them down by anticipating movements but
in the present form of the fight you
can't you just have to play this waiting
game where you backpedal and wait for an
opening or you can make the fight
completely trivial by summoning helpers
splitting their attention with dark Luka
you can anticipate slow paced ranged
attacks and plan accordingly with your
movements meaning mistakes are
completely your own with the thrown
rumors you're forced to backpedal and
stay on the edge of their attacks and
god forbid you actually try to heal
because they can launch attacks with
unpredictable warning meaning that way
you survive one time you may not survive
another you know the souls games are at
their best when damage is not left to
chance it should be left to your ability
to predict and anticipate bear in mind
I'm not complaining that the fight is
too hot I'm not it's just bringing out
the worst of the souls combat system
whereas the dark look of fight brings
out the best I do love the fact that you
have to take out the watcher and
defender evenly though that's a nice
touch and it's something that I just
wish was realized within better combat
design so dark lock is an awesome boss
you should check it out and also check
out the other 10 things episodes if you
missed them they're a lot of fun to
produce and share with you guys
oh yeah and soon we should have another
soul song ready to go so get hype and
I'll see you in the next one
later guys and thanks for supporting the
channel